Pergunta que chegou há pouco, contratar
endometriomas de forma integrativa? Sabe
quando a gente descobre um cício chamado
endometrioma e se sente meio perdida? Dá
aquela vontade de resolver logo sem
cirurgias invasivas e com carinho pelo
corpo? Pois é, hoje vamos bater um papo
sobre como tratar os endometriomas de
uma maneira integrativa, olhando todo,
OK? Então imagina você sentada com uma
xícara de chá, a gente conversando sobre
como equilibrar o corpo e a mente.
Primeiro vamos combinar o básico. Os
endometriomas são cistos nos ovários
ligados à doença endometriose.
Normalmente são removidos pela cirurgia
laparoscópica, mas isso, meu bem, pode
levar redução da reserva ovariana e até
a recorrência pode voltar em 20% dos
casos. Ou seja, a gente quer evitar
esses efeitos indesejados. Agora entre
nessa conversa comigo. Na abordagem
funcional integrativa, a gente vai além
da cirurgia e dos hormônios. Pergunta
para si mesma: o que que tá pegando para
eu não melhorar de verdade? A resposta
pode estar na inflamação, no hormônio
fora do eixo, no intestino bagunçado, no
estresse eterno, na recarga de toxinas,
enfim, tudo isso é conectado.
Dá um piro e vamos por partes. A base é
sempre a alimentação. Aquele estilo
anti-inflamatório crapichado, verduras
escuras, peixes ricos em ômega-3, frutas
antioxidantes, legumes crucíferos que
ajudam a eliminar o estrogênio. Além de
evitar ultraprocessados, glút e açúcares
refinados.
Esse comida como remédio faz maravilhas
para equilibrar hormônios e reduzir
inflamação.
E sabe, o intestino ele é chave, tem
toda uma rede de bactérias intestinais
que processam o estrogênio e é chamado
de estroboloma. Se essa rede não
funciona bem, o corpo volta a absorver
hormônios em excesso. Então, preze por
probióticos, prebióticos, que são os
alimentos fermentados e as fibras, e
cuida da saúde intestinal com carinho.
Pausa pro coração, o estresse entra no
hall, cortisol alto, piora a inflamação
e desequilibra tudo. Então, a gente faz
meditação, respiração, yoga, journaling,
que é escrever no diário todos os dias
os seus pensamentos e sentimentos. joga
fora ou não dá tempo e dá um tempo para
si. Agora as maravilhosas fitoterápicas
e suplementos que aliados temos o NAC
Nestceína mostrando redução de tamanho
da endometrioma e dor, inclusive com
aumento de chance de gravidez
espontânea. Melatonina em 10 mg por 8
semanas reduziu dor a partir da terceira
semana, além de melhorar o sono e
sintomas urinários. E não para por aí.
Temos o PEA, que é o antiinflamatório,
aliviou dor pélvica significativa em
estudos cubidando com outros agentes. Ao
mesmo tempo, curcumina, je,
endólescabinal, vitamina C e E, ômega-3,
vitamina D, acha selênio, todos com
efeitos antiinflamatórios, hormonais,
antioxidantes. Estudos sugerem melhora
na dor menstrual, dispararonia e
qualidade de vida. Tenda acupultura, que
ajuda muito no alívio da dor pélvica,
modulando fluxo sanguíneo, tensão
muscular, estresse e o toque da alma,
suporte psicológico, grupos de apoio,
fisioterapia do pavimento pélvico, do
assoalho pélvico, podem fazer toda a
diferença. São caminhos complementares à
jornada. Então, qual que é o plano? uma
estratégia personalizada juntando
nutrição defamatória, otimização do
intestino, otimização do microbioma,
suplementos comprovados como nac
melatonina e pea que eu comentei,
fitoterápicos antioxidantes, redução de
estresse com práticas mente e corpo,
acupultura, terapias complementares,
suporte emocional e corporal. Isso tudo
em parceria com profissional de visão
funcional para testes, ajustes e
acompanhamentos. E agora para fechar
nosso bate-papo, a cirurgia continua
sendo uma opção quando necessária,
especialmente quando é a situação de
endometrionas grandes ou sintomáticos,
mas com esta abordagem integrativa,
podemos potencialmente reduzir a
necessidade de cirurgia ou melhorar a
sua eficácia, protegendo a fertilidade e
cuidar da sua vida como um todo. Você
sair daqui como um mapa bacana,
comidinha amiga, cuidados do corpo e da
mente, suplementos que ajudam mesmo e
consciência de que você é parte ativo do
processo. Imagine, aos poucos o corpo
responde, a dor alivia, o futuro começa
a parecer mais leve. E aí, topa começar
nessa jornada com um pequeno passo, por
vez? M.